[Music]
mary kicks us off in kalamazoo mary
welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you so much for having me
absolutely how can john and i help
um
my husband and i are kind of in a sticky
situation with our
with my mother-in-law his mother
and
we don't really know if we should help
her how we should help her
um right now she's
going through a divorce um the reason of
the divorce
being that she is a hoarder and
her soon-to-be ex-husband says that he's
been asking for help with those but she
hasn't been helping with those
she also has a mortgage on a house that
is
unlivable it's covered in mold
and
she wants to continue to live there
um
my husband's father
passed away
i left her
i want to say about 200 000
but she's already spent it all
and while he was still alive he bailed
her out of half a million dollars in
debt
she's
yeah
she's not really being forthcoming
about any of her debt situation and she
has even gone as far to ask us not to
tell the rest of the family about her
divorce
which i think is going to be final in
about 30 days
so
now it's a situation of
and i i don't even know if this is the
correct
terminology or the correct thinking
um but is do we allow my mother-in-law
to
to live in a house that's covered in
molds that's hazardous to her health
and she's just could gonna continue to
be in debt and be a hoarder or
do we intervene somehow
how do i navigate this so mary i'll jump
in here
i hear it in you that you're just at
wit's end
and so a couple things i want to walk
you through about hoarding and then we
will get to
some steps y'all can take okay
uh
hoarding is one of those words like
narcissist that gets thrown around a lot
all over the place um if it sounds like
she truly is hoarding right she she
truly is a hoarder i'm not i'm not
saying this lately oh no i trust i trust
you i i
when somebody is fully there um when
they get a rush uh on getting a good
deal or they're unable to maneuver in
their home it's unsanitary it's unsafe
and they are unable to move forward
i want you to
begin to shift your language
just you're going to practice this i
want you to shift your language from
she's not coming she's not forthcoming
she's not
your your mother-in-law's very very ill
okay okay
um and so let's take the
moral stuff out let's take the character
stuff out um not long-term right there's
still going to be some reckoning here
and we need to change some actions and
behavior but right now she's very very
sick she's not okay
um and
we could probably track this thing back
all the way to when she was a little
girl
there's some trauma here that's been
there around for a long time it would be
my guess
but we're here now
so here's a hard truth
you can't make an adult do anything
yeah and there's few things on earth
more devastating than watching somebody
you love be in pain and not
take your help or your support or your
care because i know if she called you
and said i need this house cleaned up
this week you and your husband and
everybody else would take the week off
and go get that thing but it can't
absolutely of course you would and so
you are watching somebody that you love
drown
and you can yell all day long hey we'll
come out and get you we're here swimming
tread and water next to you and they say
leave me alone leave me alone one of the
cornerstones of
true hoarding is a deep resounding shame
she knows what her house looks like
and she's found herself in a position
where she doesn't believe she can stop
she knows about the divorce and that
some of her actions have led to somebody
saying i can't be in a relationship with
you anymore
and it just that shame mounts and mounts
and mounts and rounds and mounts so
at some point
you can rally all of your husbands
brothers and sisters and he needs to
lead this his brothers and sisters need
to lead this you need to support him in
this
this isn't your lead to take
but they either
show up with a mental health
professional and do an intervention
and say we're getting involved here
at knowing that mom can kick you all out
and or you can call some of the
resources in your community that says we
have an adult who is no longer able to
take care of themselves
and there is instances where the
local government will get involved that
gets messy mom will say mean things to
y'all
um
and that's just part of it and that's
okay because you're taking care of
somebody
but there's not going to be some magic
conversation that you the um
daughter-in-law can have and she'll go
oh i didn't think of that that's just
not where we're at she's very very sick
okay
so the reason i tell you she's very sick
i want you to approach her with
compassion not with anger and
frustration even though you're gonna get
angry and frustrated
um and let's approach it from a
compassion lens and then let's say
we're gonna give you an opportunity to
be surrounded by people who love you and
say we're willing to
get the big dumpsters in here we're
gonna help you get some care she
probably needs to go see a doctor
um not probably she for sure does
and if she won't do that then we're
gonna call in some professionals here in
the community and say hopefully they'll
reach out they may not they may not okay
okay this is a hard hard messy situation
you are in um i let her know we're not
gonna loan you money
all the brothers and sisters we're not
gonna give you money we're not gonna
give you access to our credit cards um
and we're gonna go down those roads to
make sure everybody's on the same page
that we're gonna start taking care of
mom because she's not okay
okay so the other um
the other
issue that i'm having that i'm hurting
with
um
it's just such a black and white
difference between
her parenting versus
my parents
um yeah
i i would
it's hard for me to deal with and then i
know
as as a wife and as a support to my
husband
um he's
told me that
he promised his father on his father's
deathbed that he would take care of mom
that's right and here's the deal taking
care of mom isn't giving mom everything
she wants taking care of mom
is
calling the professionals and the
interventionist who are going to help
pull her out of the water because she is
literally drowning don't compare your
parents you'll have two different sets
of parents who have different sets of
gifts and skills you love your parents
and you love her and how you love each
other it's going to look differently for
both of you you can do this oh sorry
you're going through this mary